Game of Thrones Season 7 Episode 6 begins
with our fellowship of heroes beyond the Wall.
There’s a bit of a culture clash between
Jon and Gendry and Tormund.
Gendry is from the south, while Jon is from
the north.
And Tormund, as a wildling, is from the lands
beyond the Wall, north of the north.
To him, Jon’s “north” is the south.
It’s relative.
So maybe the white walkers, who come from
the far north “Lands of Always Winter”
, would consider even the wildling lands as
south.
Gendry is mad at Beric and Thoros, cause in
Season 3, they sold Gendry to Melisandre,
who used him in a blood magic ritual.
Gendry describes Mel having sex with him,
and the Hound tells him to stop “whinging”.
Gendry’s experience with Mel was what you
might call a rape – Gendry was Mel’s prisoner,
and she pressured him into sex that he had
no option to refuse.
But the story brushes this off as no big deal,
and so did most of the viewers.
Compare that to the rape of Sansa by Ramsay
Bolton, which was similar in that Ramsay had
power over Sansa, and pressured her into sex
without her consent.
There is a difference in the trauma Sansa
felt here, compared to Gendry’s more relaxed
response.
But the fact that Sansa’s scene caused such
widespread media outrage , while Gendry’s
scene was mostly ignored, might say something
about how our society views gender and sex.
Jon and Jorah talk about Jorah’s father
Jeor, who was killed by Night’s Watch mutineers
in Season 3.
Jorah says it’s a horrible way for Jeor
to die, and Jon agrees – which is kinda
funny cause he died the same way, betrayed
by his brothers at the Watch.
Jeor gave the Mormont family sword, Longclaw,
to Jon in Season 1 – because Jorah had shamed
the family by slaving.
Jon now tries to give the sword to Jorah,
but he refuses, and says Jon should keep it.
It’s a nice gesture, but there are other
Mormonts who might wanna keep their family’s
most valuable possession.
Jorah’s cousin Lyanna could do some work
with Valyrian steel.
But Jon is the hero and must have his magic
sword.
Down at Winterfell, Arya accuses Sansa of
helping the Lannisters kill their father Ned
– which isn’t true.
Sansa repeatedly pleaded for Ned’s life
– to the queen, to the court, and at Ned’s
execution, which Arya saw.
There is this letter supporting the Lannisters
that Sansa wrote, but Cersei made her write
that – Sansa was a child and had no choice
, and Sansa tells Arya this.
But Arya just attacks Sansa for being weak
and stupid , and goes on again about Sansa’s
pretty dresses . So Arya has no real argument
here – she’s just acting out of anger
over her childhood frustrations with “pretty”
Sansa . Her anger’s understandable, but
it’s a huge lack of perspective to be threatening
Sansa for liaising with Lannisters years ago,
when there are actual Lannisters out there
right now who want to kill the Starks – Cersei
is the real enemy.
Has Arya forgotten her plan to kill the queen?
Her criticism of Sansa is also hypocritical
given that Arya served Tywin Lannister in
Season 2.
So Arya’s acting really irrationally in
this scene.
Which perfectly plays in to Petyr’s plan.
He planted Sansa’s letter to turn Arya against
her.
And now Sansa is coming to Littlefinger for
help – just as he planned.
He subtly suggests that Sansa, not Jon should
rule the north – which seems to be Petyr’s
overall goal.
He wants Sansa to rule the kingdom, and he
wants to rule Sansa.
But first, he has to deal with Arya.
Littlefinger suggests that Sansa use Brienne
to deal with Arya somehow – but it’s not
clear what exactly he’s suggesting.
Does he think Brienne would imprison or kill
Arya?
That doesn’t seem plausible.
Or maybe he wants to send Brienne away so
she can’t protect Arya?
Whatever he’s getting at, Sansa does end
up sending Brienne south to represent her
at the meeting with Cersei.
It makes sense that Sansa needs someone she
trusts at the meeting – but as Brienne points
out, it’s very risky for Sansa to send away
her most loyal protector at this dangerous
time.
Cause in her very next scene, Arya confronts
Sansa again.
And this time, Arya has an actual argument.
She suggests that Sansa wants to undermine
Jon and rule the north herself.
This is what Littlefinger was hinting at,
at Sansa might actually want it.
She has disagreed with some of Jon’s decisions.
She is proud of her role in the Battle of
the Bastards.
And she does seem to believe Petyr saying
that she is a good ruler.
So while Sansa would probably never actually
betray Jon, part of her might want to.
And Arya, with her lying game training, might
see this.
So it almost makes sense for Arya to pressure
Sansa to deter her from betraying Jon.
But pointing a knife at her sister and threatening
to kill her and wear her face is… pretty
extreme.
Arya’s motivation is again far more personal
than strategic.
Cause Sansa asks about Arya’s collection
of faces, which Arya uses to take on magic
disguises.
Arya says that the faces make her feel empowered
to take on whatever identity she wants without
being forced into gender roles . Which is
not how the Faceless Men are meant to work.
They are a cult who make you give up your
identity and become “no one”, to serve
the god of death.
But Arya is using their powerful magic for
her own personal gratification.
She’s got great power, but no responsibility.
So instead of using her magic wisely, she
uses it to threaten her sister for being mean
to her years ago.
On the one hand, this kind of fits the theme
of Arya rejecting the rules of the Faceless
Men and choosing instead to wreak revenge
on whoever she doesn’t like at the time.
But this also goes against Arya’s theme
of returning to her Stark identity, and family,
which is one of the deepest parts of her arc.
This whole conflict between Arya and Sansa
feels pretty contrived.
But it may end soon.
Bran hinted earlier that he knows things about
Petyr’s schemes – if he reveals Littlefinger’s
betrayals, the Stark girls could bond again
over bringing justice to their true enemy.
Back beyond the Wall, Tormund talks shit with
the Hound, and mentions Brienne.
Brienne almost killed the Hound in Season
4.
But Tormund has fallen in love with her.
A relationship between a wildling and a highborn
southern lady could potentially be a big deal.
In the books, Alys Karstark marries a wildling
leader, which helps solidify the peace between
wildlings and north.
Maybe Tormund and Brienne could do something
similar.
Beric speaks with Jon, and says he doesn’t
look much like his father, so he must look
his mother.
What Beric is saying is that Jon doesn’t
look like Ned.
But we know that Jon’s real father is actually
Rhaegar Targaryen – and it’s true that
Jon doesn’t look like him – with his blonde
hair and purple eyes.
Jon looks more like his mother Lyanna.
There have been so many hints this season
about Jon’s real parents – we’ll surely
get more on this mystery sometime soon.
The Hound sees a mountain that fits the vision
he saw in Ep 1 – a mountain that looks like
an arrowhead.
This same mountain was also visible in Bran’s
vision of the creation of the white walkers.
Which means that all this is taking place
near the same spot where the Night King was
born.
There’s also symbolism in the Hound looking
at a Mountain, cause his hated brother Gregor
is called the Mountain – some still hope
the two might fight.
<Tasteful airhorns>
At Dragonstone, Dany talks to Tyrion about
heroes.
She names Drogo, Jorah and Daario, who…
are all brave men, but are they really heroes?
Drogo was a brutal warlord who attacked innocent
villages to kill, enslave and rape their people.
Jorah was a slaver who fled justice, and spied
on Daenerys.
Daario is a mercenary who betrayed his own
comrades, and advises Dany to mass murder
. By most standards, these guys are no heroes.
But that’s the thing about Game of Thrones
– some of the good guys are badder than
the actual bad guys of other shows.
Dany does name one true hero, though – Jon
Snow – who almost always fights for what’s
right.
Heroes like him, Dany says, get themselves
killed – which in Jon’s case is truer
than she knows.
They talk about Cersei – who Tyrion expects
will set a trap for Daenerys when they meet
at King’s Landing.
So Tyrion says they’ll protect Dany by threatening
to burn the city if she tries anything – but
they do want to avoid deceit and murder.
It’s interesting that in previous times
when Dany met enemies, she happily used deceit
and murder – she betrayed and slayed slavers
and slaves alike at Astapor.
But if Dany wants her rule of Westeros to
last longer than it did in Meereen – she
needs people to trust her.
Tyrion raises the question of succession – who
will rule after Dany dies.
Normally it’d be the ruler’s child, but
Dany has no children, and apparently never
will.
Cause in Book 1, Mirri Maz Duur tells Dany
that she’s infertile . And Dany never got
pregnant by Daario, so it seems likely true.
So what happens to the realm after Dany dies?
Dany doesn’t wanna talk about it – she
gets prickly when Tyrion talks about her death
– a bit like a certain author we all know
. But Dany has got to work out something.
So Tyrion mentions democracy as a possible
way for Westeros to choose their next ruler
– just as the ironborn and the Night’s
Watch vote for their leaders.
This is the first real glimpse we’ve gotten
of what breaking the wheel might mean to Daenerys.
And it seems she’s serious about changing
politics and society in Westeros.
Beyond the Wall, Jon’s men are attacked
by a zombie bear, which kills some redshirts
and savages Thoros.
Beric sets the bear alight, which doesn’t
kill it for some reason – normally, fire
kills zombies good.
And the fire makes the Hound too afraid to
attack the bear, cause he’s scared of fire,
cause of his burn.
But finally Jorah kills the bear with a dragonglass
dagger.
In the books, dragonglass doesn’t seem to
hurt zombies – it only kills white walkers.
But in the show, it kills both, so the bear
goes down.
Thoros seems pretty relaxed about the hole
in his chest – he takes a swig of drink
and keeps on walking.
Leaving those poor nameless wildlings in the
snow.
There’s nothing more deadly than having
no dialogue in this show.
Thoros and Jorah talk about the Siege of Pyke,
a battle ten years ago when Thoros led a charge
against the ironborn, waving his flaming sword
like “some kind of god”.
But Thoros reveals that he wasn’t brave
– he was just blackout drunk . Which is
another of those moments in Thrones which
questions the glory of war.
Eventually the men see a small group of zombies
led by a white walker.
Maybe these guys are scouting, or hunting
for Benjen.
Jon’s men attack the dead and when Jon kills
the walker, most of the zombies fall except
for one.
Apparently zombies die when you kill the walker
that raised them.
This one zombie that survived must have been
raised by a different walker.
This is important information, cause it means
that the whole army of the dead could be destroyed
if they can just kill the white walkers – which
Jon seems to be getting pretty good at.
Also, if we assume that the Night King created
the other white walkers – though this baby
changing process – maybe killing just the
Night King would kill all the other walkers
as well as the zombies.
This whole war could end with one swing of
Jon’s sword.
The problem now, though, is that their captive
zombie screams for help, and the entire army
of the dead chases Jon’s men.
Jon chooses this moment to get Gendry to send
a message for help to Daenerys, which is terrible
timing.
Jon always knew they were facing danger, why
not ask Dany for help before they’re just
about to be killed?
Why not just have Dany come along in the first
place?
But Jon runs to a convenient island on a convenient
lake which is conveniently just frozen enough
for Jon to cross but not frozen enough to
let the dead.
Gendry marathons to Eastwatch, and sends a
raven the thousand miles down to Dragonstone,
so that Dany will fly the thousand miles up
to save them.
Which would take days.
Days of Jon’s men freezing eating and sleeping
on that island.
And all the while, the Night King and the
dead just stand and watch.
Which is… weird.
Even if they can’t cross the water, they
could just throw spears or shoot arrows or
throw rocks, right?
But the dead are patient.
They waited about eight thousand years since
the last Long Night, so they maybe they might
as well wait a few days to for the ice to
freeze.
And the walkers do seem to enjoy toying with
people.
In Book 1, they stand in a circle and watch
while a walker fights Waymar Royce , laughing
and mocking him . So watching Jon freeze and
starve might be their idea of entertainment.
Thoros dies of his wounds, and the men hold
a little funeral for him.
In Book 4, Thoros says “it does not matter
how a man begins, but only how he ends”
. Thoros began this story as a fat drunk failure
of a priest . But he dies as a warrior fighting
for life against the dead.
Check out the Thoros video for more on his
character.
The Hound, like an idiot, throws a rock that
shows the lake is frozen.
So the dead start to attack Jon’s men.
Jon uses Valyrian steel, Beric has his flaming
sword, and Tormund and Jorah and Sandor use
dragonglass weapons.
So they’ve got exactly the right tools to
counter the dead.
There are a lot of them though, so shit gets
pretty real before the inevitable Drogon ex
machina arrives.
Dany swoops in with her dragons and burns
the dead – a bit like that dream in Book
3 . But as she rescues Jon’s men, the Night
King activates his trap card, and throws an
ice spear that hits Dany’s dragon Viserion
– killing one of the only three dragons
alive in Westeros.
The King has three spears for Dany’s three
dragons – almost as though he knew they
were coming.
So some people theorise that this whole thing
was a trap.
But it’s not clear how the Night King would
know that Dany’s dragons exist – let alone
that Dany would come save Jon at this time
and place.
Dany didn’t even know she would come until
a day ago.
So unless the Night King is straight-up psychic
like Bran, the trap idea doesn’t seem likely.
After Viserion dies, Jon decides not to immediately
get on Drogon and fly away, but instead to
kill some more zombies and take a dip in the
lake.
So Dany leaves without him.
If Dany had decided instead to attack the
Night King – to burn him, or crash a dragon
into him – she could’ve ended this whole
war there and then.
But, she flees.
And leaves her child Viserion dead in the
lake.
Jon survives – because at this point falling
into water is practically a guarantee that
a character will survive.
Then he faces the army of the dead and prepares
to die – a bit like he did at the Battle
of the Bastards.
You’d think that after dying and being reborn,
Jon would’ve learned to stop throwing himself
into impossibly dangerous situations, but
it seems he’s decided he can take as many
risks as he likes and he’ll always survive.
Cause he always somehow does – Benjen saves
him at the last minute and Jon gets away again.
One of the moments that defined Game of Thrones
Season 1 was the death of Ned Stark, which
showed that when good guys make bad mistakes,
they die.
In Season 3, Robb and Catelyn made mistakes
and they died.
But by rescuing Jon from certain death over
and over and over, saving Jaime, saving Arya
– it takes away the tension and drama.
Every time this happens, we care less.
Jon’s reunion with Benjen is one of the
most long-awaited moments in the series.
For years – five books and seven seasons
– Jon has been hoping to see his uncle again.
And in the books there are hints that Benjen
knows secrets about Jon’s birth – he was
involved in the Knight of the Laughing Tree
incident which may have led to Jon’s parents
hooking up – go watch that video.
But in the show, there’s no time for that
detail.
Benjen turns up, says ‘Hi, I’m a zombie,
goodbye”, and decides he’d rather die
than share a horse with his nephew.
It does feel a bit anticlimactic, but there
is pathos implied in Ben’s death.
Benjen has apparently been surviving in the
north on his own as a zombie man for years.
He’s probably suffered in ways that we can’t
imagine.
But he kept fighting all this time until he
got the chance to do something noble, saving
Jon, before letting go – he was ready to
die, and ended it on his terms.
So the reunion’s a bit janky, but there
is meaning here.
The Hound carries the captive zombie through
the Wall.
The way this seems to work is that the dead
can pass through the Wall only when the living
carry them through – like with Othor and
Jafer Flowers in Season 1.
But the magic of the Wall stops the dead getting
through uninvited . That being the case, you’d
think that Benjen could have crossed the Wall
if someone just carried him – but he’s
not an ordinary zombie, so he might work differently.
Either way, the heroes have succeeded in their
insane plot to catch a zombie.
Hopefully it’ll be worth it.
Dany stands on the Wall and waits for Jon,
or maybe she’s hoping for Viserion.
The dragon doesn’t come, but Jon does – collapsed
on his horse just like he was in Season 3.
Dany sees his chest and learns that he really
was stabbed in the heart, and that he’s
been keeping up with his situps.
When he wakes, Jon says he’s sorry about
the death of her dragon – Dany did say that
her dragons are the only children she’ll
ever have.
But some people speculate that the death of
Viserion might allow Dany to have kids again.
Because Dany’s infertility seems to be a
sort of a curse from Mirri Maz Duur, who once
said that only death can pay for life.
Maybe the death of her dragon will allow Dany
to make life again.
Dany and Jon having kids might well be on
the cards, from all the talk of kids and succession
this episode, and from the way Jon and Dany
are looking at each other lately.
Even though they’re aunt and nephew – in
fact due to generations of royal in-breeding,
this is, like, super-incest.
But regardless, Jon says he’ll kneel to
Dany and make her his queen, finally forming
a great alliance to face the dead.
Meanwhile, the dead pull Viserion out of the
lake, like ants pulling a worm.
Some people have questioned how the dead got
these chains – but the walkers have been
around for thousands of years, it’s plausible
enough that they found some chains from a
ship or a merchant or that scythe at some
point.
So they pull out the dragon, and the Night
King raises it as a zombie – a Blue Eyes
Wight Dragon.
Since the Night King turns the dragon by touching
it, it seems possible that this dragon is
now more like a white walker than just a regular
zombie – like how the Night King changed
that baby.
The baby was alive though, while Viserion’s
dead.
So there’s lots of uncertainty about what
the zombie dragon’s powers will be.
Will it breathe fire?
Seems unlikely, when fire kills zombies.
Maybe it’ll breathe frost, like an ice dragon,
which is a whole other thing, a species of
dragon that’s made out of ice.
Whatever the specifics, zombie dragons are
really bad news.
This is NK getting nukes, and they will use
it.
No one is safe, and Dany and Jon must bring
fire and fury to stop them.
In this episode, Beric says that the enemy
is death, and “Maybe we don’t need to
understand any more than that”.
It’s like Beric is telling the audience
we don’t need to understand how Jon survived
on that island for days, or why the Night
King stood and watched.
We don’t need to understand why Arya suddenly
turned on her sister.
Or how Jon survives again and again.
Or how Cersei’s reign works politically.
And maybe we don’t need to understand.
But Game of Thrones at its best isn’t just
about battles and dragons.
It’s complex politics and human drama that
makes you think.
David and Dan do an amazing job of adapting
a story that George Martin wrote to be unadaptable
– and at this point they’ve even run out
of books to adapt.
But hopefully these last seasons of Thrones
can conclude the story without losing that
layer of detail and depth that makes Thrones
unique.
Thanks for watching.
Thanks to Patrons Jesse Deal, Charlie Fox,
Hannah Hurst, Nicola Thompson, Bruno Zorzi,
Shelbelle and Jpop Olopolous.
Cheers.